that's it myself next leg war that's it
but some Jets let's go that's it but
someplace slam world selling bad or you
know what a lot of people that watch
more YouTube videos they kind of almost
restricted because they got found in but
maybe their partner they they loved with
all their heart he's really skeptical
don't go to the crash course you know
don't you know it's a pipe dream and
usually a partner that says that it's
actually trying to protect you and they
do want the best for you of course they
do otherwise they wouldn't be with you
and as it's Valentine's Day today I
thought I'd give some relationship
advice
[Music]
so here's my advice my advice is if your
spouse husband wife girlfriend boyfriend
is not really fully supporting you in
your property journey or as an
entrepreneur would be don't try and win
them over
don't try and win them over with words
just show them let the results speak for
themselves don't defend your position
you know just let the results speak for
himself go and package and saladin and
make 2,000 pounds and then use that
money to take them on a beautiful little
holiday somewhere you know or or or buy
them a freakin Gucci handbag or whatever
it might be but just show them let the
money speak because ultimately if you're
making money and you do that that is the
results so if you're watching this and
you've got a miserable partner don't try
and win them over don't try and get
their approval just show them your
results if they're not happy at that
point if you've made some money and
they're still not happy then maybe you
need to find a new partner but I can't
say that because today is Valentine's
Day so I've got to keep it positive so
that's my advice
[Music]
but right now I'm just backstage hello
Mae how you doing
[Music]
[Music]